you're welcome brother I think about
this interaction a lot you know a lot of
people struggle with some of my content
at first you know in my content I'm so
candorous in real life I struggle with
that believe it or not but the content I
put out for y'all I'm going at it at the
heart when I kind of know someone and I
love them it's a little harder to say it
to them but this interaction means the
world to me and I think can really help
a lot of you in communicating to the
people you love like when you go to the
place and you go real with them it
really allows them to self-reflect once
they're ready to self-reflect so you
deal with some of the short-term pain
it's kind of like kids or people that
you manage like they may not love it at
first but they'll love it in the end